l'enchantement du repas de noël passe
par la décoration et notamment avec un
centre de table une fabrication à partir
d'une mousse aspergé d'eau sur laquelle
on commence par planter des morceaux
deux sapins la base de cet élément
décoratif
[Musique]
donc là on va partir sur une idée de
base d'un centre de table allongé dans
les tons rouge et blanc vous avez de la
rose avalanche pour celle ci qui est une
variété magnifique et qui tient très
bien donc là vous voyez on a pris donc
un petit père noël qui tout au plus
classique
on va commencer à mettre un petit peu de
feuillages teintées pour vraiment
rappeler l'esprit fait dernières touches
avec la bombe de paillettes pour obtenir
des végétaux scintillant chez cette
fleuriste les décorations côtoie
notamment l'étoile de noël le point ccja
une fleur spécifique aux fêtes de fin
d'année elle partage son succès avec les
roses rouges noires et blanches
la magie de noël touche son commerce au
mois de décembre son chiffre d'affaires
est multiplié par trois c'est une
période sur laquelle on pourrait pas se
passer noël clairement ça représente en
fait nous ça démarre notre saison noël
on va dire l'an dernier selon un sondage
mené auprès de 2500 français 76% des
personnes interrogées envisageaient
d'acheter de nouvelles décorations
[Musique]
et voilà la décoration est terminée